Gençler merhaba. Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Sınıflandırma konusuna başlıyoruz. Benim
en favori konularımdan bir tanesi
biyolojide okur yazar olmamızı sağlayan
temel konulardan. Bu ne demek?
Hatırlarsanız biyolojiye başlarken dedim
ki birazcık konu ilerlememiz lazım ki
artık bize bir şeyler tanıdık gelsin.
Mesela bunlardan bir tanesi temel
bileşenler, diğeri hücre ve organeller.
Üçüncüsü de sınıflandırma.
Sınıflandırmada canlıları kategorize
edeceğiz ve bunun temel mantığını
anlamaya çalışacağız. O zaman ne
diyoruz? Hadi gelin birlikte öğrenelim.
Neden sınıflandırma yaparız sorusunu
sorarlar hep. 1. Nesli tükenen
canlılarla şimdiki türleri kıyaslamak
için. 2. Ekolojik ve ekonomik
kaynakların farkına varmak için. 3.
Dünyadaki çeşitliliği algılayabilmek
için. 4. Yeni keşfedilen türü doğru
tanımlayabilmek için. Bu yüzden
sınıflandırma yaparız ve sınıflandırma
bilimi taksonomidir.
İlk sınıflandırmayı yapanlardan Aristo
ampirik sınıflandırma yapmış. Bakın A
harfi, A harfi, A harfi. Ampirik
sınıflandırma. Aristo analog organlara
bakılarak yapılmış. Nedir hocam bu?
Canlının yaşadığı ortam ve dış görünüş
dikkate alınmış. Canlı uçuyor mu,
yürüyor mu, yüzüyor mu? Buna bakılmış.
Peki analog organ nedir? Kökeni farklı,
işi aynı organ. Yani burada o klasik
örneği verelim. Kelebek kanadıyla kuş
kanadı 1 sayılmış. Çünkü ikisi de uçmaya
yarar. Peki bu sınıflandırma bize yeter
mi? Tabii ki yetmez hocam. İşte
yetmeyeceğini Carlinle zamanında
anlamış. Carlin bilimsel
sınıflandırmanın temelini atmış. Tabii
kimin üzerine inşa etmiş temeli? John
Ray
ve onun tür tanımı üzerine. Ve tür için
ne diyoruz biz? Ortak atadan gelen
çiftleştiklerinde verimli döller veren
canlılar aynı türde bulunurlar. Dönelim
hocam. Şimdi öyleyse filogenetik
sınıflandırma yani doğal sınıflandırma
yani bilimsel olan sınıflandırma
Carlin'nin ve John Rey'in eseri aslında
bilimsel sınıflandırmanın temel
şablonudur. Canlıların moleküler
yapısına, anatomisine, fizyolojisine,
biyokimyasına, embriyolojik gelişimine
bakılarak sınıflandırma yapılır. Ve
bakın dikkat edin. Burada homolog
organlar dikkate alınır. Homolog
organların mantığında köken aynı, iş
aynı ya da farklıdır. Önemli değil. Yani
ben işe odaklanmıyorum. Bakın birisi
yüzmeye, birisi tutmaya, birisi uçmaya
yarayan organın içerisindeki anatomik
yapılara bakıyorum. Ve eğer köken
aynıysa ben bunlara homolog organ
diyorum. İnsan kolu, balina yüzgeci, kuş
kanadı bu tarz örnekler veriyorum.
Dolayısıyla homolog organ filogenetik
sınıflandırmanın bel kemiği. Hocam bir
de simetri diye bir şey var. Radyal
simetri, bilateral simetri. Vücut
simetrisi. Çok karşımıza çıkmıyor ama
yine de anlatalım. Bilateral simetride
düzlemi şu şekilde ikiye bölersiniz ve
sola sağa düşen parçalar birbirine
eşittir. Ancak şu şekilde kestiğiniz
zaman öne ve arkaya düşen parçalar eşit
değildir. Biz anatomide arkadaşlar
düzlemleri çok severiz. sagital,
frontal, koronal ya da işte horizontal,
transfers düzlemler ifadelerini çok
kullanırız. O yüzden bu aslında
anatominin de bir parçası. Bilateral
simetriye baktığınız zaman omurgalı
canlılarda ve bazı omurgasılarda
görürüz. Ama radyal simetri nedir hocam?
Radyal simetriyi aslında bir bardağa,
kulpsuz bir bardağa benzetebilirsiniz.
dikene kesitler aldığınızda her
seferinde yanlara, öne arkaya, sağa sola
düşen parçalar birbirinin aynısıdır
şeklinde bir ifade kullanabilirsiniz.
İşte dediğim gibi omurgasız canlılarda
mesela hidrada bunu görebilirsiniz.
Filogenetik sınıflandırmada yapmadığımız
şey nedir derseniz bize biz kromozom
sayısına bakmıyoruz. Çünkü kromozom
sayısı gelişmişlikle alakalı bilgi
vermez. Neden hocam? insan, moli balığı,
kurt bağrı bitkisi, 46 kromozomlu. Şimdi
bunlar aynı türe mi mensup? Hayır hocam.
Peki Ağrel to bazı bitkilerde mesela
yüzlerce kromozom var ama bende 46
kromozom var. Eelotu bizden daha mı
gelişmiş? Hayır hocam. Dolayısıyla
kromozomun sayısı canlının gelişmişliği
ile ilgili bilgi vermeyecek.
Sınıflandırmanın temel birimi neydi?
Türdü. Ve John Ray tarafından arkadaşlar
bu tanımlanmış. İlk defa Karlin de
bilimsel sınıflandırmayı tür ifadesinin
üzerine kurgulamış ve adlandırma sistemi
geliştirmiş. Karlin demiş ki biz bu
canlıları artık adlandıralım. Bu
çiftleştiğinde verimli döller verir
ifadesine baktığınız zaman arkadaşlar
aslında bir soyğacı çizmenizi istiyorum.
Bu soy ağacında da şu şekilde A canlısı,
B canlısı, Csı oluşsun. Bakın burada A
ve B aynı tür müdür şeklinde bir soru
sorsalar oladabilir olmay daabilir
diyeceksiniz. Ama eğer C Dyla çiftleşip
K gibi bir canlıya sahip olursa yine CD
ile alakalı konuşmam ama A ile B'nin
aynı tür olduğunu söylerim. Neden? Çünkü
bakın çiftleştiklerinde verimli bir
yavruları olmuş. O çocuk sahibi olmuş.
Yani siz bunların torun sahibi olup
olmadığına bakarak bu yorumu
yapabilirsiniz. Bu şekilde bir soyağcı
tadında sorusu var arkadaşlar. Şimdi
binominal adlandırmada bazı kurallar var
arkadaşlar. Mesela kelimelerden ilki
büyük harfle başlar. İkincisi küçük
harfle. Her iki kelimede italik yazılır.
Yazalım buraya. İalik yazılır.
İlk kelime büyük harfle başlar.
İkinci kelime tanımlayıcıdır.
Ve birinci kelime ki buna yıldız atın.
Cins adıdır. Yani özellikle ve öncelikle
buna bakacağız. Birinci kelime cins adı.
İkinci kelime özellik. Bir tanımlayıcı
kelime. İkisi birden arkadaşlar tür adı
olacak. Bakın Pantera Leo ve Pantera
Tigris. Bu iki canlı bir cinsin
iki farklı türüdür şeklinde
yorumlayacaksınız. Hani hocam ben
canlıları bu şekilde tanıyabilir miyim?
İşte Pinus Nigra, Pinus alba, popüs
alba. Hayır. Bunların sana ne anlam
ifade ettiği önemli değil. Sen gidip de
bütün canlıların bilimsel adlarını
öğrenemezsin. Ama hocam o kuralı bilmen
lazım. Kural neydi? İtalik yazılacak.
İlk kelime büyük harfle başlayacak.
Birincisi cins adı olacak. İkincisi
özellik ya da tanımlayıcı bir kelime.
Yani sıfat gibi düşünün. İkisi birden
tür adı olacak. Sınıflandırma
basamaklarına baktığımız zaman tür,
cins, aile, takım, sınıf, şube alemi
görürüz. Bakın arkadaşlar, mesela az
önce bahsettiğimiz Pantera Leo ve
Pantera Tigris'i yazacağınız zaman
nereye yazarsınız? Buraya yazarsınız.
Ama Pantera'yı buraya yazarsınız.
Ailesi nedir bunun? Bunlar
kedigillerdir.
Etçildir bunlar. Sınıfına baktığınız
zaman memelidir. Şubesi kordalıdır. İşte
kordalıların omurgalı grubudur bu. Ve
hangi alemde? Tabii ki hayvanlar
alemindedir. Yani gördüğünüz gibi bu
şekilde aslında bir bilimsel
kategorizasyon vardır. Biz bunların her
birine arkadaşlar bu her bir basamağa ne
diyoruz? Takson diyoruz. Ve buradaki
kurallar bellidir. Diyorsunuz ki türden
aleme doğru gidildikçe ne azalır diye
bir soru sorarlarsa bakın daha genele,
daha kalabalığa gidiyorsunuz. ortak
özellik azalır.
Protein benzerliği azalır.
Gen benzerliği azalır.
Peki türden aleme doğru gidildikçe ne
artar hocam? Çeşitlilik artar,
birey sayısı artar
vesaire vesaire. Şimdi bir tane soru
sormak istiyorum arkadaşlar. Genelde
bize derler ki şunu çizerler. X ve Y
canlıları var ve bu iki canlı aynı
ailede. Buna göre hangi taksonda
birlikte bulundukları kesindir?
Hangilerinde oladabilir, olmay daabilir?
Şimdi bunlar aynı ailedeyse hocam
bunların hangi cins ya da hangi tür
olduğuna karar veremezsin. Ama aynı
aileye kadar gelmişse takımı, sınıfı,
şubesi, alemi aynı olmalı. O zaman
yazalım. X ve Y aynı aile içinde
bulunuyorsa
nerede kesin birlikteler?
Cevap hocam. Takım, sınıf, şube, alem.
Yani genel olan yerde birlikteler özel
olan yerde olabilir, olmay daabilir. Ve
siz arkadaşlar böyle bir mantığa göre
bir canlıyı embriyonik döneminde
incelediğinizde aslında canlının önce
şube özelliği ortaya çıkar.
En son tür özelliği ortaya çıkar.
Yani bu ne demek? Aldınız elinize bir
hayvanı, hayvan embriyosuna
bakıyorsunuz, sırtında sinir şeridi var.
Hım, bu kord dalalı diyorsunuz ama daha
bunun ne olduğunu bilmiyorsunuz.
Türe kadar inmeniz için bir sürü
araştırma yapmanız lazım. Yani genelden
özele doğru gitmek demek, alemden türe
doğru gitmek demek. O yüzden en genel
olan yerde birlikteler ancak spesifik
yerleri bilemeyiz arkadaşlar. Şimdi
burada bir soru var arkadaşlar. Bir X
canlısının kanı şekildeki gibi A, B ve C
gibi 3 farklı canlının kanı ile
karıştırıldıktan sonra çökelme
oranlarına bakmışlar. A, B> C olarak
saptanmış. Buna göre X canlısına olan
akrabalıkları yakından uzağa doğru
sıralayınız. Şimdi arkadaşlar bir yerde
çökelme kelimesini görüyorsanız çökelme
savaşma demek. Böyle kodlayabilirsiniz.
Bakın şimdi mantığa. Ben kiminle
savaşırım? Tanımadığımla. Nerede çok
savaşmışım? Burada. Öyleyse bu bana en
uzak akraba, bu ise en yakın akraba.
Dolayısıyla X'e olan akrabalığı yakından
uzağa sıraladığında CBA olmalı. Şimdi
buraya kadar bir sıkıntı yok.
Şöyle bir soru geldiğinde bütün fabrika
ayarlarınız bozuluyor ama bir A
canlısının kanı bir B canlısının kanıyla
karıştırılıyor. Sonra B canlısından
alınan serumlar sırasıyla C, D''ye
aktarılıyor. Burada %5, burada %25,
burada %55 çökelme oluyor. Bunlardan
hangisi A canlısıyla yakın akrabadır
diye soru soruyorum. Sen diyorsun ki
hocam C
değil. Neden değil? Çünkü bu soruyla
bunun bir alakası yok. Bak 1ci soruda
ben doğrudan çökelmeye baktım ve kimde
çok çökelme varsa o en uzak akraba
dedim. Ama burada böyle olmuyor hocam.
Bak, A canlısıyla B canlısının kanını
karıştırdığında Bde buna antikor
oluşuyor. Şimdi diyelim ki A canlısında
şöyle antijenler var ve ben bu
antijenlere karşı B canlısında bu
şekilde antikorlar oluşturdum. Doğru mu?
Bu antikorları şimdi gideceğim ve C'ye,
D''ye, E'ye aktaracağım. Bunlar ne
yapacak peki? Antijen bulacak. Bu %5
bulmuş. Bu %25 bulmuş.
Bu %55 bulmuş. Yani antijen daha çok
bulunmuş E'de. Antijen kimlik demekti.
Kimlik burada daha fazla varsa o zaman E
ile yakın akrabadır diyeceksiniz. Çünkü
değilinin değili kendisi olacak. Bakın
değilinin değili kendisidir. Yani
bununla bu soruyu lütfen karıştırmayın.
Bu videodaki son başlıktayız. Hücresel
yapıya göre sınıflandırma yapıyoruz.
Bakın prokaryot ve ökaryot. Artık bunu
biliyorsunuz. Prokaryot nedir? Zarlı
organel ve çekirdeği olmayacak. Ökaryot
zarlı organel ve çekirdek olacak.
Prokaryotlar bakteri, arke. Ökaryotlar
protist, bitki, mantar ve hayvan. Peki
neden hocam ikisi de prokaryot olmasına
rağmen aynı başlık altında incelenmiyor
bu bakteri ve arkeler? Hemen buraya şunu
yazmanızı istiyorum. İki tane temel
neden var. Bunlardan bir tanesi
ribozomal RNA. Bir başka ifadeyle
ribozomlardaki farklılık ki arkadaşlar
her şey bununla başlamış. Bilim
insanları bunların ribozomlarındaki
farkı fark ettikten sonra aynı başlık
altında incelenmemeleri gerekir
demişler. İkincisi tabii ki
DNA'larındaki diziliş arkadaşlar.
DNA'larındaki
gen dizilişindeki farklılık. Dolayısıyla
bunlar farklı alemler demişler. Ve hatta
aslında şöyle bir ifade var. ortak ataya
götürmüşler işi ama domain diye bir
kelime ortaya atmışlar. Aslında
alemlerin de üstünde bir kelime var.
Bakterya, arkea ve ökarya. Bakteriler,
arkeler ve ökaryotlar şeklinde üç tane
domainle canlıları sınıflandırıyorlar.
Konu içerisinde sürekli vurgulayacağım
ama burada da söylemek istiyorum.
Prokaryotla protist ifadesini
karıştırmayın arkadaşlar. Protist
dediğiniz zaman bakın burada protista
ökaryot bir alem ama prokaryot ifadesini
kullandığınızda bakteri ve arkeye
gidersiniz. Bir de şuraya dikkat edin
lütfen. Bakteri, arke, protista, bitki,
mantar, hayvan şeklinde prokaryottan
ökaryota doğru canlıların alemleri
gösterilmiş. Bu öylesine gösterilmiş bir
çizim değil arkadaşlar. Burada basitten
karmaşağa doğru gidiliyor aslında. Ve
dikkatinizi çekmek istiyorum. Mantar
bitkilerden daha gelişmiş. Bakteri en
ilkel buraya göre. Sonrasında arke,
protista, bitki, mantar, hayvan aslında
bir gelişmişlik sırasıdır aynı zamanda.
Evet, bir mola. Çayınızı, kahvenizi
tazeleyin. İkinci videoda bakteri ve
arkeler olacak.
Yeah.